bonsoir nicolas sarkozy de retour à la
tête de l'ump c'était le 29 novembre il
ya presque un mois fin des discours
place à l'action quels sont les
changements qu'il a opérés au sein de sa
formation politique et surtout qu'en
pensent les militants je recevrai tout à
l'heure aux rats en berger membre du
collectif une droite avance et
conseillère municipale d'opposition à
magny les hameaux à la joue un rôle
important dans la campagne de l'ancien
chef de l'état pour retrouver la
présidence de l'ump
pour le moment j'accueille philippe
chevrier responsable départemental du
front national bonsoir et bienvenue sur
ce plateau scrutin départemental en mars
22 29 mars
mi décembre un sondage qui donne votre
formation en tête des intentions de vote
au premier tour à 28% des sondés contre
25 % à l'ump 17 % au parti socialiste
même si en général pour les élections
vous ne prêtez pas beaucoup attention
aux sondages celui ci a dû vous faire
plaisir
oui bien sûr mais vous avez raison de
dire rien n'est joué on est quand même à
trois mois de l'élection 28% bien sûr ça
nous fait plaisir c'est encore un peu
mieux que le résultat des européennes
mais voilà restons calmes travaillons et
essayons de mériter ces 28 bon vous avez
revu à la hausse son objectif
aujourd'hui en france le front national
ces deux conseillers généraux sur
l'ensemble du territoire ça doit être
autour de deux conseillers généraux à
peu près ce que j'ai pu retrouver deux
neutrons deux élus les élus deux élus
sur l'ensemble du territoire
c'est ce qui peut se dire donc vous
savez dans ces chiffres n'hésitez pas de
regarder nous anovo j'espère oui
certains mais honore aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui comme aujourd'hui je suis en
amour et excusez moi nous n'en avons que
deux aujourd'hui c'est que c'était
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est 2 quels
sont les objectifs alors pour 2015
je pensais m'en de faire le rouble le
mien personnel enfin l'estimation
personnel que je fais c'est une centaine
une certaine sur l'ensemble du
territoire et jeu c'est vrai que dans
mon propre parti je suis plutôt classés
dans les optimistes d'accord pourquoi
vous expliquer ce qu'est ce qui va vous
jouer des tours c'est quoi si à des
triangulaires il va y avoir des appels à
voter contre le front national des
désistements de droite comme de gauche
un barrage alors nationale je pense que
d'abord eu d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'abstentions et que du fait de ces
abstentions
au deuxième tour il y aura rarement
d'eau triangulaire donc ce sera en
général des duels
vous savez que pour se maintenir faute
vous entendez troisième photo 5 des
inscrits donc c'est généralement 20 25%
des des votants et donc si vous faites
20 25% des votants vous n'êtes pas
troisième en général vous êtes deuxièmes
donc il se sera plus tôt ce sera plutôt
des duels et donc si ce sont des duels
contre la gauche
on sera à mon avis plutôt bien placé et
je pense qu'il y en aura pas mal si ce
sont des duels contre l'ump ce sera
peut-être un peu plus difficile c'est à
dire que vous misé beaucoup sur
l'électorat ump
et bien sûr bien sûr sur les tories de
droite
oui bien ce qu'on entend à l'ump n'y
aura aucune alliance avec avec le front
national mais les partis sont bien
séparés que chacun reste chez soi que
nos électeurs restent chez nous c'est le
message qui est actuellement véhicules
et à l'ump un oui et puis on en a aussi
qui viennent gillot a donc bon c'est pas
c'est pas tout à fait bon il ya le
langage officiel
et puis il ya ce qui se passe en réalité
cette élection bien qu'elle soit
éminemment politique
là aussi des incidences locales est bon
sur le plan local il est très possible
qu'il y ait des accords va pas dire des
alliances mais des accords techniques
avec l'ump au niveau du département de
l'ump ou alors avec des personnes
ponctuelles dans certains quand je pense
des personnes puissent se plus il a déjà
le rapprochement des discussions avec
certains élus sortants par exemple pas à
titre personnel non pas à titre
personnel mais je sais que ça existe
j'ai eu des discussions dans les
yvelines justement quels sont les
objectifs du front national eh bien
écoutez il y aura des candidats partout
ça vous l'avez déjà on est quand même
oui on est quand même très en dessous
des scores du national le maire général
je rappelle que aux européennes on est
sept points en dessous du niveau
national niveau national était à 24 nous
étions à 17 dans les yvelines bien
donc nous partons de 17 en fait c'est un
peu ça alors même si il ya trois points
de mieux là au niveau national
ça nous met à 20 c'est insuffisant dans
un scrutin à deux tours
un binominal maintenant à deux tours bon
c'était c'est insuffisant
bon malgré tout dans certains cantons on
a un peu au dessus j'ai bon espoir j'ai
bon espoir de faire rentrer des élus au
sein du département suppression sur des
secteurs plus ça peut arriver ça peut
arriver quand vous dites vous avez bon
espoir sur quel canton par exemple quels
sont les cantons particulier sur les
cages de l'audio globalement les cantons
du nord qui jouxte la scène ont misé
beaucoup sur la candidature de série no
aussi dit le maire de montants bien
évidemment que j'ai été élu et qui se
présentera face à pierre bédier
bien sûr bien sûr on sera à fond
derrière lui pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que c'est cyril noter ensuite
parce que c'est monsieur bédié justement
parce qu'on a certaine vision de la
manière dont il s'est comporté récemment
qui fait que
ce sera quelqu'un qu'on essaiera de de
contrecarrer donc y aura une campagne
très active sur ce sur ce secteur
demande sur le canton demande
il y aura des candidats partout ça on
l'a déjà dit aujourd'hui tous les
candidats sont désignés quel est le
processus encore en cours en cette fin
d'année les candidats sera alors au plan
national sont en train d'être désigné
pour ce qui concerne les yvelines s'est
pratiquement tout fait sauf deux trois
cantons qui reste encore à déterminer
il y aura des binômes c'est le
changement on l'a évoqué c'est difficile
de trouver des binômes
c'est un champion du dahlia moins deux
cantons mais il ya tout autant de
candidats puisque maintenant on vote
pour des dix nommés c'est un changement
important
voilà une femme ou femmes hommes femmes
dans ce qu'ils font là parité à c'est la
parité
ils sont vraiment à égalité c'est une
difficulté je ne conteste pas parce que
les gens sont pas habitués les candidats
sont pas habitués partager une campagne
avec quelqu'un d'autre c'est quelque
chose de difficile il faut faire des
choix dans une campagne il faut donc
qu'on soit d'accord les deux en plus
c'est un homme une femme la vision des
hommes ne sont pas forcément les mêmes
que ceux des femmes
donc je vois que dans d'autres parties
est plus plus importants comme par
exemple l'ump lui dit vous savez que
dans les yvelines l'ump lui dit on fait
des alliances déjà fait largement corps
est là sont déjà connus je vois qu'il ya
un homme ump une famille d donc ou le
contraire d'ailleurs
donc ça doit poser que chez eux aussi
des petits soucis c'est par des gros
problèmes
les listes c'est des petits soutenu
définitive quant à la rentrée 2015
janvier 2015 j'espère bien faire ça je
fais tout pour ça j'espère pouvoir faire
une conférence de presse mi janvier un
non sens tous les noms on va tout de
même faire un focus sur quelques uns des
cantons qui y touche saint quentin en
yvelines sur le canton de trappes il ya
déjà des candidats déclarés pour l'ump à
mener a notamment par jean-michel
fourgous mais pas uniquement vous l'avez
dit ce sont des binômes
et puis sur le ps et il aura sans doute
une division avec peut-être une
candidature communiste soutenu par
europe ecologie les verts c'est encore
en discussion et les socialistes qui
partiraient tout seul rien n'est encore
officiel mais c'est plutôt sa sueur
vous avez déjà désigné votre candidat
écoutez on nicolas beau père qui est
conseiller municipal d'opposition l
encours qui revient oui pour la cause
d'allah c'est pour l'homme
maintenant pour coter femmes c'est un
peu plus difficile ça se partage entre
trappe et il encourt donc on ne sait pas
encore exactement comment ça va ça va se
jouer
pardon entre ap et maurepas excusez moi
voyez que sur un autre corner botté par
page voilà effectivement maurepas qui
est maintenant changer de deux cantons
qui se rapproche de de magny les hameaux
de condé sur aisne c'est un secteur
plutôt large
là aussi les candidats ump ps ont été
dévoilées récemment à ismail havane
conseiller général sortant et ils
vendent val conseiller général sortant
également puisque ce sont deux cantons
qui ont fusionné
donc on a deux candidats sortants qui
vont s'affronter ça aussi c'est inédit
vous avez déjà pas encore donc des noms
de candidats sur marc pas pour le front
national voilà mais pour le pour le même
souci quoi donc et sur montigny alors
d'un touche sur lui en propose sûrement
pas quand même quand tu es hommes on
aura vincent texier pardon votre
question et la question c'est est
surmontée autres continents y va tout
naturellement sylvain grisons et lui
sera accompagné de martin verbe
merci et bonne raison qu'ils étaient
candidats au conseil municipal sur la
ville de montigny le bretonneux 2008
vous étiez vous même candidat à
rambouillet 7% et quelques vous repartez
en campagne écoutez je repartirais sans
doute en campagne du moins je suis
candidat à la candidature
mais la commission d'investiture n'a pas
encore rendu son verdict donc ce sera
pas forcément seront pas forcément sur
rambouillet sur le fond à présent parler
des candidatures mais on aura le temps
d'y revenir au cours des prochaines
semaines sur les les noms des personnes
qui vont se présenter sur le faux sur
les axes de campagne pour ce programme
les compétences du conseil général du
département c'est l'aide sociale
l'éducation avec les collèges
l'aménagement avec les routes où même
les équipements euros également
il va falloir aussi faire des économies
ce sera une question je poserai tout à
l'heure mais votre campagne va porter
sur quel point précis les finances donc
on ne vient plus vite les économies très
clair c'est les financent
essentiellement alors vous faites des
économies sur l'aide sociale l'éducation
sur l'aménagement des routes
écoutez
on va regarder des comptes de très près
je vais faire une juste une incidence
sur les municipalités
parce que ce qu'on depuis que nous
sommes rentrés dans une dizaine de
villes au niveau national mais également
dans les conseils municipaux
une dizaine de conseils municipaux dans
les yvelines
on s'aperçoit que notre présence dans ce
désastre dans ces assemblées change
énormément de choses
d'abord ça nous permet d'avoir accès aux
chiffres on découvre des choses qui sont
invraisemblables exemple et bien que
certaines villes sont au bord de la
faillite 6 6 7 6 et compte là étaient
des comptes privés de société
ces sociétés seraient en faillite comme
une fonction visto les communes où se
trouve le front national non mais
vraiment je vais vous dire je vais vous
dire rambouillet prenons en juillet les
112e rambouillet rambouillet disons des
comptes à peu près équilibrés gentiment
équilibré
sauf que rambouillet s'est engagé dans
des investissements très lourds un opéra
cetera
très récemment et que dans le même temps
les dotations budgétaires de l'état vont
se réduire et donc très rapidement si on
se projette sur deux trois ans on voit
qu'il va y avoir un effet de ciseaux et
que ce cette pauvre municipalité va
devoir soit faire des économies très
importantes en matière de personnel
puisque c'est le poste le plus important
après s'il ya quand même 500 personnes
qui sont à la mairie de rambouillet à
quels seraient mes séparés seulement si
vous étiez majoritaire à rambouillet
pour faire des économies
ce serait quoi ah ben ils sont là les
postes ah c'est sûr et certain le
conseil général pour se projeter et n'y
a pas et il n'y a pas d'autre ce que je
ne sais pas je ne connais pas les
comptes encore du conseil général mais
je vois là je ce que je vois ce que je
vois avec avec des communautés de
communes aussi on on sait au niveau
national que depuis que les communautés
de communes ont été créés
les communes elles mêmes n'ont pas
réduit leur personnel donc il ya une
espèce d'aberration là quelque part
parce que normalement on aurait dû à due
concurrence
c'est les effectifs des mairies bien
entendu puisque c'est à compétences
égales c'est juste un transfert de
compétences d'un niveau à un autre
eh bien non eh bien non donc vous voyez
que ce millefeuille dans ce millefeuille
on a rajouté une feuille et finalement
qui n'apporte rien qui n'apportent pas
en tout cas la valeur ajoutée qu'on
aurait pu l'espérer
voilà donc c'est fort de cette
expérience je fais très court mais quart
monde et regroupe en fait rarement
d'elancourt par exemple elle encore est
dans une situation terrible élan corp
est déjà à zéro en marge brute s'est
déjà 0 avec la baisse des dotations
budgétaires de l'état mais c'est une
boîte que punk quasi faillite
donc forcément sur les finances pour le
conseil général mais on aura pour la
priorité sur la kz2 programme on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir il nous reste
quelques instants j'aurai tout même
faire réagir sur un autre sujet alors
que plus nationale on va pas parler de
la routine de florian philippot par
closer il y avait quasi unanimité
d'ailleurs de tous les partis politiques
pour le soutenir sur 7 sur 7 sur ce
procédé qui d'ailleurs était plutôt
dénoncer pour atteinte à la vie privée
elle est on va pas parler non plus de
l'emprunt du front national à la russie
ce goût des responsables nationaux en
ont parlé mais juste sur le rapport avec
les médias aujourd'hui quel est le
rapport des médias quels rapports vous
entretenez avec les médias quand on voit
que mediapart le petit journal n'ont pas
le droit au rendez-vous du front
national au congrès notamment que marine
le pen aussi attaquent régulièrement les
journalistes
quels rapports aujourd'hui entretien
entretien le front national avec les
médias dont l attaque pas les
journalistes en général et la sacd sir
alice mais aujourd'hui est ce que la
politique du front national toujours
vis-à-vis des médias c'est simple contre
tous ce nom n'est pas ce qu'on attendait
il y à des journalistes qu on a
identifié comme étant des journalistes
militants bien à partir de là d'ailleurs
on leur en veux pas particulièrement
c'est bien de ce fait normal qu'une
personne soit militante ce qu'on dit il
faut le dire voilà il faut être clair
quand un journaliste et militant il faut
qu'il le dise
et s'il ne le dit pas à nous le
dénonçons lorsqu'ils concernent médias
parlent parfois quelques journalistes de
canal+
voilà c'est nous sommes dans cette
situation là donc ça c'est pour l'import
avec les journalistes nationaux et
forcément vous pose la question parce qu
on a échangé autour de ça déjà
auparavant mais pas à l'antenne quel
rapport entretient le front national
avec tv fil 78 et si je vous pose cette
question très brièvement pour les
téléspectateurs pour leur expliquer les
nouvelles émissions sur tv fils je
présente je reçois les les élus des
différentes communes
récemment le maire d'elancourt jean
michel fourgous est venu comme les
autres élus pour cette émission nous
sollicitons le responsable majoritaire
de l'opposition qui intervient à travers
deux questions qui sont enregistrés et
diffusés via une tablette le maire
répond ensuite et nicolas beau père pour
le site et ensuite fait une intervention
au conseil municipal s'indignant de ne
pas avoir été sollicité il ya aussi en
campagne avec des tracts distribués sur
la ville et il parle de collusion entre
le pouvoir ump s la télévision locale
que c'était une nouvelle démonstration
de cet état de fait j'aurais juste
savoir si c'est la position officielle
du front national dans le département
vis-à-vis de terrifier 78 et que les
choses soient claires sur cette antenne
avant que ne s'ouvre une campagne
électorale prochainement moi je veux
être très clair je soutiens à fond la
démarche de nicolas bauer 6 r la
question vous me posez je crois qu'il
s'est senti mis à l'écart d'un débat qui
le concernait et donc voilà il a réagi
je pense qu'il a raison de réagir je ne
vois pas pourquoi ils se relancent en
milieu réagirait pas par rapport à
quelque chose qui nous qui nous
défavorise je voudrais réagir laissant
que nous défendons tout à fait réagir et
nous sollicitaient demander pourquoi il
n'a pas été interrogé on lui aurait fait
la même réponse d'ailleurs j'ai eu cet
échange via les réseaux sociaux avec lui
pour ceux qui ont suivi ces échanges
il n'empêche que ce tract dénonce une
collusion une nouvelle fois je cite un
du pouvoir ump s avec tv fil 78 vous
avez le sentiment à l'issue de cet
entretien puisqu'il est terminée que mes
questions n'étaient pas objective vos
questions sur tout il n'y a pas de
question qu'ils ne soient pas objective
les questions en question la
redéfinition et son objectif mais
question et après l'interprétation qu'on
en fait où les questions et les
militants tous les ump où le découpage
qu'on puisse faire d'un entretien ça
c'est autre championnat n'est pas
forcément dire ap ap une page la bombe
et c'est très bien parfait qu'il sera
objectif mais question faisant la bise
et im pei ps par contre le nombre
d'invitations vous faites à l'ump
par rapport au nombre d'invitations au
front national
je serais intéressé d'avoir cette
statistique
pour en parler juste après cette
émission il n'y a aucun sens car nous
puisque qu'effectivement nous ne sommes
pas favoris alors pas traitées sur un
plan d'égalité alors je vous ferai la
même réponse que je vous ai déjà fait
hors antenne il existe le csa n'hésitez
pas à le solliciter à le saisir nous
tenons les comptes et nous n'avons
jamais eu aucun problème tout a été
vérifié et vous y avez accès je vous le
redis on pourra encore en parler merci
en tout cas d'être venu philippe
chevrier sur ce plateau vraiment très
gentilles attendu j'espère que vous
reviendrez donc juste le temps d'une
virgule et un nouvel invité va me
rejoindre sur ce plateau
il sera candidat à la primaire de l'ump
en 2017 pour le compte du parti chrétien
démocrate jean frédéric poisson actuelle
la députée de la 10e circonscription des
yvelines se montre particulièrement
actif en ce moment prises de position en
faveur de l'installation des crèches
dans les espaces publics vote à
l'assemblée contre une proposition de
résolution visant à réaffirmer le droit
fondamental à l'interruption volontaire
de grossesse ou encore opposition au
travail le dimanche ou à la réforme
voulue par françois hollande sur la fin
de vie est celui avec qui débuta en
politique aux côtés de christine boutin
veut se faire entendre on notera aussi
qu'au début du mois il organisait un
dîner de bienfaisance en l'honneur des
chrétiens d'orient il juge que la france
les a abandonnés nous allons à présent
parler du premier bilan de nicolas
sarkozy
mais j'aimerais tout d'abord aurore
bergé bonsoir et bienvenue vous faire
réagir sur ces informations concernant
jean frédéric poisson
vous êtes membre du collectif une droite
davance conseillère municipale
d'opposition à magny les hameaux parti
chrétien démocrate qui est un allié de
l'ump est ce que vous vous retrouvez
dans les idées qui sont défendues par
jean-frédéric poisson
moi je suis une sensibilité qui est
différente et vous le savez en même
temps moi je pense que c'est important
qu'on ait des primaires et les primaires
ouvertes et dans ce cadre là il va bien
falloir qu'on ait des candidats qui
représente des sensibilités différentes
moi je trouve ça bien que dans ce cadre
jean frédéric poisson il présentait sa
candidature
ça ne pose pas de souci d'avoir des
écarts aussi grand dans les positions
vis-à-vis de certains sujets je pense
arriver j'ai par exemple moi il me
semble sur libé zay
j'aurais préféré qu'il vote la
résolution mais il me semble que le
sujet principal pour lequel il ne l'a
pas votée n'est pas qu'il est contre les
jets mais il était contre le changement
de législation qui fait que maintenant
il n'y a plus la notion de détresse dans
la loi donc il faut pas non plus
caricaturer ses prises de position sont
pas forcément liés à ces primaires ne
sont pas des caricatures opposé j'aime
pas trop qu'on caricature mes prises de
position parfois s'avérer poissons et
avec les autres surtout qu'il n'est pas
là en plateau mais il est le bienvenu il
le sait d'ailleurs s'il souhaite devenir
pour un prochain 7,8 politique on va
laisser de côté le parti chrétien
démocrate
on va vraiment se concentrer sur l'ump
là c'est le thème de cet entretien cela
fait presque un mois que nicolas sarkozy
a pris la tête de votre famille
politique un an après quel bilan vous
faites ce que vous êtes satisfaite des
actions qui ont été engagés et déjà
depuis un mois ça va mieux dans ce parti
on respire mieux dans ce parti on a on a
vécu en léthargie un peu pendant deux
ans maintenant après la défaite à la
présidentielle puis aux élections
législatives en 2012
on a eu très belle victoire lors des
élections locales j'espère que cela va
s'amplifier avec les départementales du
mois de mars puis avec les élections
régionales et on avait malheureusement
un parti qui au niveau national n'avait
plus vraiment de tête et au delà de
l'absence de leadership n'avait plus de
lignes d'initiatives dans vie là je
pense qu'on est en train de la retrouver
avec nicolas sarkozy avec une nouvelle
équipe qui l'a nommé auprès de lui je
pense notamment à nathalie kosciusko
morizet avec laquelle je travaille je
veux savoir samazan que cette union
justement ça fonctionne bien dans les
coulisses avec rachida dati nadine
morano ça se passe bien aussi
vous savez il ya les petites phrases que
certains aiment bien encore des petites
phrases
l'arrivée de nicolas sarkozy va pas
enlever toutes les petites phrases au
mais je pense que les décibels ont quand
même un petit peu baissé depuis qu'il
est là il me semble que le chef de
l'opposition aujourd'hui de manière très
claire c'est nicolas sarkozy et ça
c'était le véritable enjeu parce que les
françaises avaient plutôt l'impression
que le vrai chef de l'opposition
s'appelait marine le pen et moi j'ai pas
envie d'un second tour avec marine le
pen en 2000
cet avion vers moi engagée contre le
front national aujourd'hui la campagne
les prochaines campagnes qui vont
souffrir
la campagne s'est principalement
l'adversaire c'est fou rationnelle et
pas la gauche c'est pas ça nous on a un
parti qui dit on pour une autre idée de
la france que celle qui aujourd'hui en
actions en actions encore suis gentil au
sein du gouvernement et on n'a pas envie
que les français aient le choix entre
soit la reconduction de l'existant qui
nous mène vers une situation économique
et sociétal compliqué difficile et un
choix qu'elle celui de la radicalisation
de l'exclusion et du repli avec le front
national dont il faut bien qu'une autre
voix puisse exister et pour qu'on puisse
porter une autre voix forte
il fallait déjà qu'on ait enfin une
clarification du leadership au sein du
parti du principal parti d'opposition
l'élu aux électeurs c'est clair la
différence entre l'ump et le front
national je vous pose la question juste
avant vous à votre place sur cette
émission ne recevions philippe chevrier
le responsable départemental du front
national et nous disait si un second
tour front national ps on aura les
électeurs de droite qui vont nous
soutenir et nous disaient qu'ils avaient
déjà des discussions dans les coulisses
avec certains certains élus certains
responsables politiques pas au niveau
complètement départementale mais des
personnes qui discutaient avec le front
national des gens de l'ump qui discute
avec le front national que lui ça rentre
dans son petit plan de com de dire ça
très bien
s'il a envie de lancer ce genre de
rumeur grand bien lui fasse
moi je lui rappellerai juste que marine
le pen a participé à l'élection de
françois hollande en 2012 clairement en
appelant à voter blanc en appelant à
voter même contre nicolas sarkozy
donc les alliés objectifs politiques
c'est le front national et la gauche
pourquoi la gauche aujourd'hui est
encore à la tête de certaines régions et
des principales régions parce que il y a
eu ce qu'on appelle des triangulaires
front national droite et gauche et que
nous nous avons refusé de nous allier
avec le front national
c'est la raison pour laquelle le parti
socialiste s'est maintenue donc nous ne
sommes pas les alliés du front national
il n'y aura aucun accord électoral avec
le front national
nicolas sarkozy l'a redit j'étais à la
réunion des cadres de l'ump
c'était samedi dernier je peux vous dire
que c'est très clair il est même allé
plus loin
certains étaient tentés par un
quelconque accord avec le front national
ou appelaient à voter en faveur du front
national il serait immédiatement exclu
du parti donc
très clair et j'aimerais bien qu'on
arrête d'essayer d'en fermer l'ump dans
ce sujet là parce que c'est pas le sujet
principal
parce que de toute façon ça n'a pas
existé et ça n'existera pas le projet de
l'ump aujourd'hui qui va être proposé
prochainement vous l'attendez sur quels
points très précis le projet qui sera
proposé après le conseil national de
l'ump ce sera la fin du mois de janvier
vous attendez quels engagements clairs
de la part de l'ump l'a justement on est
en train de le définir
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas demander
comme ça en une semaine de définir un
nouveau projet pour le pays il faut
d'abord qu'on réfléchisse
nicolas sarkozy m'a nommé dans la
commission des statuts de l'ump
l'idée c'est justement de réfléchir à
quelle doit être la nouvelle
organisation du parti
comment on fait pour attirer des
nouveaux publics comment on fait pour
les fidéliser comment on fait pour
s'ouvrir comme il avait réussi à le
faire de 2004 à 2007
mais aujourd'hui à la fois les outils
ont changé avec le numérique les
attentes des français ont changé
donc il faut déjà que nous on se
modernise et puis ensuite je pense qu'il
va falloir quand même qu'on se
positionne sur d'autres sujets que ceux
sur lesquels on a été audibles ces
dernières années moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on arrête
par exemple cette question du mariage
pour tous et qu'on se concentre sur des
sujets qui sont vitaux pour l'avenir de
notre pays je pense à la refondation de
l'école par exemple
au final le seul sujet sur la
refondation de l'école depuis deux ans
ça a été la réforme des rythmes
scolaires justement sur les rythmes
scolaires s'il veut l'ump revient au
pouvoir il faut supprimer cette réforme
moi je pense qu'il faut pas faire comme
ça a été fait là c'est à dire sans
aucune concertation avec les avec les
maires ou d'un coup en impose et on
donne pas les moyens
donc si jamais il faut revenir sur cette
loi
je pense qu'il faut laisser le choix en
fait aux collectivités de revenir sur la
loi ou non d'amendés ou non et pas comme
ça se fait d'autoritarisme d'état qui
est assez paradoxal en plus quand il
s'agit de la gauche qui est plutôt
normalement décentralisatrice il faut
laisser le libre choix mais je pense que
cette réforme n'était pas prioritaire
n'aurait pas dû s'organiser comme ça
qu'elles coûtent très cher aux
collectivités qu'elles créent aussi des
vraies inégalités de territoire entre
celles qui ont les moyens et celles qui
en ont pas je pense que sur le fond le
mode de fonctionnement qui n'a pas été
une bonne réforme qu'il faudra
probablement revenir dessus mais on peut
pas à la fois avoir condamné nous la
méthode est appliqué la même pour
revenir dessus qu'il faudra négocier
dialoguer donc l'éducation chantiers
importants vous nous disiez vous
attendez quelques l'ump s'investissent
là dessus il ya d'autres axes tous les
enjeux aujourd'hui économique
on voit bien ce que certains essayent de
faire sur la question européenne en
essayant finalement de de faire croire
que toutes les décisions seraient prises
dans ce ps de gros monstres froids que
serait bruxelles où ils oublient que
toutes les décisions sont prises avec la
présence de la france
et qu'ensuite elles sont mises en oeuvre
par nous mais elles ont été négocié au
préalable
donc je pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on
arrive à tordre le cou à certaines idées
reçues et certain populisme que certains
acteurs politiques aiment bien utilisé
et que sur les enjeux économiques
on est une autre option que celle qui
est de dire comme le front national il
faut sortir de l'euro
donc il va falloir aujourd'hui qu'on ait
un vrai discours sur le fond on voit là
le débat sur la loi macron il ya un
certain nombre de choses où on sait
qu'au cas par cas sur certains sujets on
aurait pu voter et être en accord avec
certaines dispositions
il va falloir aussi que nous on
travaille sur ces sujets les professions
réglementées outre ça c'est pour le font
juste pour conclure sur sur la forme une
dernière question votre nom a circulé
pour prendre la tête des jeunes
populaires lorsque nicolas sarkozy
voudra aussi de réformer s'occuper de
réformer un petit peu ce mouvement et
pourquoi pas d'en désigner le ou la
responsable d'être candidat de vous
souhaiteriez six points ça se passe pas
comme ça encore une fois je vous dis
j'ai été nommé dans la commission
guinchard je vous en avais parlé ou pas
voir votre nom est ordinaire soir il pas
un parti mais moi je suis je suis ravi
que certains aient envie de sortir mon
nom que d'autres justement pour parce
qu'ils ont peut-être une inimitié
aimerait même le faire sortir pour mieux
après le casse et j'en sais rien et ça
m'est égal en fait et franchement je
pense que tout le monde s'en fiche
moi je suis nommé dans une commission de
révision des statuts pour bosser donc
c'est ce que je vais faire oculaire set
j'ai commencé j'ai commencé mois à
travailler à rencontrer des
interlocuteurs d'autres partis européens
pour dialoguer avec eux voir comment ils
s'organisent et c'est un travail est
passionnant que je fais en lien avec
nathalie kosciusko morizet qui préside
cette commission
on a quatre mois c'est à la fois long et
en même temps ça va falloir aller très
vite
moi je me concentre sur le boulot après
10 bien ce qu'ils veulent c'était le
feuilleton politique de 2014 le retour
de nicolas sarkozy nous verrons comment
se traduit ce come back en 2015 merci
aurore bergé
merci à vous on se retrouve en janvier
sûreté des fils pour un nouveau
cette fuite politique bonne soirée